in 2013 I thought there is no way we can
learn 10 million or 100 million
classifiers and even if you could learn
them where would we store them and even
if you could store them how would we
make a prediction in a millisecond and
so I just turned away from one versus
all approaches and we've tried
developing craze in embeddings but today
we've actually managed to overcome all
of those limitations and the key trick
is to go from linear time training and
predictions to long time training and
prediction you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Music]
if every question in life could be
answered by choosing from just a few
options machine learning would be pretty
simple and life for machine learning
researchers would be pretty sweet
unfortunately in both life and machine
learning things are a bit more
complicated
that's why dr. Monica Pharma principal
researcher at MSR India is developing
extreme classification systems to answer
multiple choice questions that have
millions of possible options and help
people find what they're looking for
online more quickly more accurately and
less expensively on today's podcast
dr. varma tells us all about extreme
classification including where in the
world you might actually run into ten or
a hundred million options reveals how
his parable and slice algorithms are
making high-quality recommendations in
milliseconds and proves with both his
life in his work that being blind need
not be a barrier to extreme
accomplishment that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Manik Varma welcome to the podcast
thanks Christian the pleasures and
bailey mine so you're a principal
researcher at MSR india and an adjunct
professor of computer science at iit
delhi in addition to your work in
computer science you're a physicist a
theoretician an engineer and a
mathematician you are a Rhodes Scholar
at Oxford and a university scholar when
you did your doctoral work there and you
were a postdoc at msri Berkeley and
you're blind I'm not gonna call you
Superman but I would really love to know
what has inspired you to get to this
level of accomplishment in your life
what gets you up in the morning I guess
it's a combination of my hopes and
desires on the one hand I guess fears as
well on the other
so I guess hopes and desires I hope
every day I get up I learn something new
that's one of the best feelings I've had
and that's what's driven me all this
while and actually that's why I'm in
research because I get to ask new
questions and learn about new things
throughout my career so that's fantastic
and the other hope and desire that I
have that drives me is to build things
and build things that will help millions
of people around the world and I guess
there's some fears looking behind that
as well I've been worried about the
imposter syndrome all my life yeah so I
guess the best way to tackle that is
actually to try and do things and get
things out there and have people use
them and be happy with them so I guess
that's the fear that's driving the hopes
and desires so monic all of this has
been without the use of your eyes how
have you gone about all this right so I
have condition where the cells in my
retina deteriorate over time so in about
2009 I think I started using a blind
stake and then I lost the ability to
read papers then recognize faces stuff
like that it makes life very interesting
right I go up to my wife and ask who are
you that's the secret happily married
life
well so you haven't been blind since
birth no okay
well it's a hairy condition but nobody
else in my family has it so it started
deteriorating from the time I was in
school and I lost the ability to do some
things in school but it's only over the
last let's say ten years where it's
become really significant but again it's
been no big deal also right it's only in
the last decade where I've had to think
about it and that's I think it because
of my kids right I want to set them an
example that taken because this is
headed Italy there's probability they
might have it and if they do I don't
want them to feel that they can't do
something right so if they want they can
go climb Mount Everest or become the
best historian or the best scientist or
whatever as long as I said their minds
up they can do it hmm we're gonna talk
about this relatively new area of
machine learning research called extreme
classification in a minute but let's
start a bit upstream of your current
work first give us a quick review of
what we might call the machine learning
research universe as it were focusing on
a bit of the history and the types of
classification that you work with and
this is just to give us a framework for
how extreme classification is different
from other methodologies and why we need
it so if you look at the history of
machine learning then the most well
studied problem is binary classification
where we learn to answer yes/no
questions involving uncertainty and then
the community realized that actually
there are many high impact applications
out there in the real world that are not
just simple yes/no questions right
they're actually multiple choice
questions and this leads to the field of
multi-class classification and then
after that the community realized that
there are some high impact applications
that are not only multiple-choice but
they also have multiple correct answers
and this led to the establishment of the
area of multi-label classification
so just for take examples of all of
these if you ask the question is
Gretchen speaking right now or not then
that's binary classification well if you
turn this into a multiple choice
questions such as who's speaking right
now is it
or Manik or Satya Nadella so that's a
multiple-choice question that will be
multi-class classification but now
suppose you threw a cocktail party and
you invited all the top machine learning
scientists over there and then you took
a short clip and asked who's speaking in
this clip that becomes a multi-label
classification problem because now
multiple people could be speaking at the
same time and so if you have L choices
in front of you then in multi class the
output space is L dimensional order l
but if you have a multi label then the
output space is two to the power L
because every person may or may not be
speaking so you go from two choices in
binary classification to tens to
hundreds and thousands of choices in
multi class and multi-label learning and
if you looked at the state-of-the-art in
about 2012 the largest multi-label
datasets out there had about 5000 labels
and I remember all my colleagues like
running their algorithms for weeks on
big clusters to transform this problem
because 2 to the power 5000 is way more
than the number of atoms in the universe
so this has been a problem for quite
some time it's not brand new right but
it's getting bigger
is this our issue right and actually
that's how extreme classification got
started so as I mentioned in 2012 the
largest publicly available multi-label
datasets 5000 labels but then in 2013 we
published a paper which exploded the
number of labels being considered in a
multi label classifier from five
thousand to ten million Wow and that
really changed the nature of the game so
the motivating application was to build
a classifier I could be used as a tool
by advertisers that would predict which
Bing queries would lead to a click on
the ad or the document and you can well
imagine from the context of the
application that this is a really
important problem from both research as
well as a commercial perspective and so
many sophisticated natural language
processing machine learning information
retrieval techniques have been developed
in the literature to solve this problem
but unfortunately none of these were
working for our ads team they had
billions of ads
for which all these sophisticated
approaches were not making good quality
predictions and so we decided to go back
to the drawing board we set aside all of
these approaches and simply we
formulated the problem as a multi-label
classification problem we would take the
document as input and then we would
treat each of the top queries on bing as
a label so we took the top ten million
monetizable queries on bing and now you
just learn a classifier that will
predict for this particular document or
ad which subset of top ten million being
queries will lead to a click on the ad
top ten million from five thousand to
ten million this was just a very
different and completely new way of
looking at the problem and it took us
two years to build this system run the
experiments publish our results and
check everything out but once the
results came in we found that our
approach was much better than all these
traditional approaches so the number of
ads for which we are making good quality
recommendations went up from about 60%
for the Bing system to about 95 98
percent for us and the quality of our
recommendations also improve the Lord
and so that led to the establishment of
the area of extreme classification which
deals with multi class and multi label
problems in extremely large label spaces
in millions of billions of labels and I
think that's exactly why extreme
classification grew to be a whole new
research area in itself and that's
because I think fundamentally new
research question also arise when you go
from let's say a hundred labels to 100
million labels let me just give you a
couple of examples if you permit me the
time yes please
the whole premise in supervised machine
learning is that there's an expert
setting out there who we can give our
data to and he or she will label the
data with ground truth what's the right
answer what's the right prediction to
make for this but unfortunately in
extreme classification there is no human
being who can go through a list of 100
million labels to tell you what are the
right predictions to make for this data
point so even the most fun
mental machine learning techniques such
as cross-validation might go for a toss
at the extreme scale and you will have
missing labels in your test set in your
validation set in your training set and
this is like a fundamental difference
that you have with traditional
classification where a human being could
go through a list of 100 labels in Marc
or the right subset another really
interesting question is the whole notion
of what constitutes a good prediction
changes when you go from a hundred
labels to let's say 100 million when you
have a hundred labels you need to go
through that list of 100 and say okay
which labels are relevant which labels
are irrelevant but when you have a
hundred million nobody has the time or
patience to go through it so you need to
give your top five best predictions very
quickly and you need to have them ranked
with your best prediction at the very
top and then the worst one at the bottom
and you need to make sure that you
handle this missing labels problem
because some of the answers that you
predict might not have been marked by
the expert so all of this changes as you
go from one scale to the next field
[Music]
let's talk for a second about how
extreme classification can be applied in
other areas besides advertising tell us
a little bit about the different
applications in this field and where you
think extreme classification is going I
think one of the most interesting
questions that came out of our research
was when or where in the world will you
ever have 10 million or 100 million
labels to choose from you just think
about it for a minute
a hundred million is a really large
number this will put it in context to
see how big a number this is when I was
doing my PhD in computer vision the
luminaries in the field would get up and
tell the community that according to
Biederman's counts there are only 60,000
object categories in the world so none
of the classical visual problems will
make the cut and even if you were to
pick up a fact oxford english dictionary
it would have somewhere around half a
million words in it so many traditional
NLP problems might not also make the cut
and over the last five years people have
actually found very high-impact
applications of extreme classification
and so for example one of them leads to
reformulations of well-known problems in
machine learning like ranking and
recommendation which are critical for
our industry so suppose you wanted to
for instance design a search engine you
can read each document on the web as a
label and now when a query comes in you
can learn a classifier that will take
the queries feature vectors input and
predict which subset of documents on the
web are relevant to this particular
query and so then you can show those
documents and you can rank them on the
strength of the classifiers
probabilities and you can reformulate
ranking as a classification problem
and similarly think about like a
recommendation right so suppose you were
to go onto a retailer's website they
have product catalogs that run into the
millions if not hundreds of millions and
so no human being can go through the
entire catalog to find what they're
looking for and therefore recommendation
becomes critical for helping users find
things they're looking for
and now you can treat each of the
hundred million products that the
retailer is selling as a particular
category and you learn a classifier that
takes the users feature vector is input
and simply predicts which subset of
categories are going to be of interest
to the user and you recommend the items
corresponding to those categories to the
user and so you can reformulate ranking
and recommendation as extreme
classification and sometimes this can
lead to very large performance gains as
compared to traditional methods such as
collaborative filtering or learning to
rank or content based methods and so
that's what extreme classification is
really good for let's talk about results
for a minute how do we measure the
quality of any machine learning
classification system I imagine there
are some standard benchmarks but if it's
like any other discipline there are
trade-offs and you can't have everything
so tell us how should we think about
measurement what kinds of measurements
are you looking at
and how does extreme classification help
there so the axis along which we measure
the quality of a solution our training
time prediction time model size and
accuracy so let's look at these one by
one and they're all linked also so if
you look at training time this is
absolutely critical for us we cannot
afford to let our extreme classifiers
take months or years to train so think
of the number of markets in which Bing
operates all over the world if it were
to take you let's say two days to train
an extreme classifier then every time
you wanted to deploy in a new market
that would be two days gone every time
you wanted to run an experiment where
you change a feature two days gone every
time you want to tune hyper parameters
2d is gone and again when I'm saying to
it is this is probably on a cluster of a
thousand cores right so how many people
or how many groups have access to those
kinds of clusters whereas if you could
bring your training time down to let's
say 17 minutes of a single core of a
standard desktop now you can run
millions of experiments and anyone can
run these experiments on their personal
machines and so the speed with which you
can run experiments and improve the
quality of your product and
Yoga rhythm there's a sea change in that
yeah so training time becomes very
important but as you pointed out right
you want to maintain accuracy so you
can't say oh I'll cut down my training
time but then I will make really bad
predictions that's not acceptable and
then the second thing is model size so
if you your classifier is going to take
let's say a terabyte to build its model
then your cost of making recommendations
will go up you need to buy more
expensive hardware and again the number
of machines that have a terabyte is
limited so the number of applications
you can deal with in one go is limited
so again you want to bring your model
size down to a few gigabytes so that it
can fit on standard hardware and anybody
can use this for making predictions and
again there's a trade-off between model
size and prediction time right you can
always trade speed for memory but now
the question is how can you bring down
your model size to a few gigabytes
without hitting your prediction time too
much and the reason prediction time is
important is because again at the scale
of being we might have a hundred billion
documents that we need to process
regularly so if your prediction time is
more than a few milliseconds per
document then there is no way you can
make 100 billion predictions in a
reasonable amount of time so your
solution simply will not fly and all of
this as I said is tied to accuracy
because people will not suffer poor
recommendations no I won't well so
circling back how does extreme
classification impact your training time
model size speed accuracy all of that if
you look at the people that we are
publishing now like parable and slice we
can clean on that same data set in as I
said 17 minutes of a single core of a
standard machine and so we've really
managed to cut down training time let's
say by ten thousand times over the span
of five years we've managed to reduce
our model size from a terabyte to a few
gigabytes or prediction time is a few
milliseconds per test point and we
managed to increase accuracy from about
19%
Genet one to about 65% today so
precision at one is if you just look at
the top prediction that was made was
that correct or not so on a standard
benchmark data say was 19 percent in
2013 and we managed to increase that to
65 percent today so there's been a
remarkable improvement in almost all
metrics over the last five six years you
just mentioned parable and slice and
let's talk about those right now first
of all parable it's a hierarchical
algorithm for extreme classification
tell us about it and how its advanced
both the literature of machine learning
research in the field in general so for
the last five years we've been trying
out lots of different approaches to
extreme classification we tried our
trees we tried out embeddings and deep
learning and we looked at one versus all
approaches and in one versus all
approach you have to learn a classifier
per label and then you use all of them
at prediction time to see which ones
have the highest scores and then that's
the classes or the labels you recommend
to the user and in 2013 I thought there
is no way we can learn 10 million or 100
million classifiers and even if you
could learn them where would we store
them and even if you could store them
how would we make a prediction in a
millisecond and so I just turned away
from one versus all approaches and we
tried developing trees in embeddings but
today we've actually managed to overcome
all of those limitations and the key
trick is to go from linear time training
and predictions to log time training and
prediction and originally I thought this
is not possible right because you have
to learn one classifier per label so if
you have 100 million labels you have to
have a hundred million classifiers so
your training time has to be linear in
the number of labels but with parable we
managed to come up with a log time
training and a long time prediction
algorithm and the key is to learn a
hierarchy over your labels so each node
in the hierarchy inherits only about
half of its parents labels so there's an
exponential reduction as you go down the
hierarchy and that lets you make
predictions in logarithmic time now the
trick in parable was how do you make
sure the
the training is also logarithmic time
because at the leaves of the hierarchy
you will have one let's say label in the
leaf node and so you have to have at
least as many leaves as classify so that
gives you back to linear costs but
somehow parable you'll need to read the
paper in order to get the trick it's a
really cute trick and what you can get
away with log buying cleaning and so
that's why parable manages to get this
ten thousand times speed up in
prediction in training in reduction in
model size and accuracy is great it's a
really cool algorithm more recently
you've published a paper on what you've
called the slice algorithm what's the
key innovation in slice how is it
different from or how does it build on
parable alright so slice is also of one
versus all algorithm when you learn a
classifier per label it also has log
time training and prediction but it's
based on a completely different
principle so in parable our approach was
to learn a hierarchy so you keep
splitting the label space and half as
you go down each node slice has a very
different approach to the problem it
says okay let me look at my entire
feature space and now if I look at a
very small region in the feature space
then only a small number of labels will
be active in this region so now when a
new user comes in if I can find out what
region of feature space he belongs in or
she belongs in very quickly then I can
just apply the classifiers in that
region and that's the key approach that
slice takes to cutting down training
time and prediction time from linear to
logarithmic and it's about to appear in
wisdom this month and it scales to 100
million labels I mean if you look at
image net right so that was a thousand
classes with a thousand training points
per class and now we have a hundred
million classes so we used it for the
problem of recommending related searches
on bing so when you go and type in a
query on a search engine the search
engine will often recommend other
queries that you could have asked that
might have been more helpful to you or
that will highlight other facets of the
topic and so for obvious queries the
recommendations are pretty standard and
everyone can do a good job
real fight is in the tail for these
queries that are rare that we don't know
how to answer well can you still make
good quality recommendations and they're
getting even a 1% lift in the success
rate is a big deal like it takes
dedicated time and effort to do that and
we managed to get a 12 percent lift in
performance with slice in the success
rate so that's like really satisfying
yeah and you had some other percentages
that were pretty phenomenal too in other
areas can you talk about those a little
right so we also saw increases across
the board in Trigger coverage suggestion
density and so on so triggered coverage
is the number of queries for which you
could make recommendations and we saw
52% increase in that 50 yeah that's
right and then the suggestion density is
the number of recommendations you make
per query and there was a 33% increase
in that as well
so yeah we had pretty significant lift
and I'm very glad to say like slices
making billions of recommendations so
far and people are really happy it's
really improved the success rate of
people asking queries on being so far
that's cool
speaking of where people can find stuff
I imagine a number of listeners would be
interested to plunge in here where can
they get this is it available where are
the resources so we maintain an extreme
classification repository which makes it
really easy for researchers and
practitioners who new to the area to
come in and get started if you go to
Bing and search for the Xtreme
classification repository or your
favorite search engine you can find it
very easily and there you'll find not
just our code but you'll find datasets
you will find metrics on how to evaluate
the performance of your own algorithm
you'll find benchmark results showing
you what everybody else has achieved in
the field so far you'll find
publications and if you look at my home
page you'll also find a lot of talks so
you can go and look at the recordings to
explore more about what
area fascinates you and all of this is
publicly available freely available to
the academic community so people can
come in and explore whatever area of
extreme classification they like
[Music]
so Manik we've talked about the large
end of extreme classification but
there's another extreme that lies at the
small end of the spectrum and it deals
with really really really tiny devices
tell us a bit about the work you've done
with what you call resource efficient ml
yeah that's the only other project I'm
working on and that's super cool too
right because for the first time in the
world we managed to put machine learning
algorithms on a microcontroller that's
smaller than a grain of rice think of
the possibilities that opens up right so
you can now implant these things in the
brains of people who might be suffering
from seizures to predict the onset of
the seizure you could put them all over
a form to try and do precision
agriculture will tell you where to water
where to put fertilizer and way to put
pesticide in all of that the
applications are completely endless
especially once you start thinking about
the Internet of Things number of
applications in the medical domain in
smart cities smart housing so in 2017 we
put two classical machine learning
algorithms based on trees and nearest
neighbors called bonsai in photon or
until this microcontroller it has only
two kilobytes of RAM 32 kilobytes of
read-only flash memory no support and
hardware for floating-point operations
and yet we managed to get our
classifiers to run on them and then last
year we released to record neural
network algorithms called first year in
an EMI organelle and again all of these
are publicly available from github so if
you go to github.com slash Microsoft
slash HML you can download all these
algorithms and play with them and use
them for your own applications so while
we're on the topic of your other work
you said that was the only other project
you're working on but it isn't
and maybe move inside together but I've
also heard you're involved in some
rather extraterrestrial research can you
tell us about the work you're doing with
SETI yeah so a bit related but
apparently some of these algorithms that
we've been developing could have many
applications and astronomy and
astrophysics
so if you look at our telescopes right
now they're receiving data at such a
high rate that it's not possible to
process all of this data or even store
all of this data so because the
algorithms we've developed are so
efficient if we could put them on the
telescope itself it could help us
analyze all types of signals that we are
receiving including perhaps our search
for extraterrestrial intelligence so
that's a really cool project being run
out of Berkeley but there are also lots
of other applications because if you're
trying to put something on a satellite
I'm told by my astronomer friends that
the amount of energy that an algorithm
can consume is very limited because
energy is at a premium out there in
space and so things that are incredibly
energy efficient or will have very low
response time or very interesting to
astronomers so Monica asked all my
guests some form of the question is
there anything that keeps you up at
night you're looking at some really
interesting problems big ones and small
ones is there anything you see that
could be of concern and what are you
doing about it
extreme classification touches people
people use it to find things they're
looking for
and so they reveal a lot of personal
information so we have to be extremely
careful that we behave in a trustworthy
fashion where we make sure that
everybody's data is private to them and
this is not just at the individual level
but also the corporate level right so if
you're a company that's looking to come
to Microsoft and leverage extreme
classification technology then again
your transaction history in your logs
and stuff will make sure that those are
private and you can trust us and we
won't share that with anybody else and
because we're making recommendations
there all these issues about fairness
about transparency about explain ability
and these are really important research
challenges and ones that we are thinking
of at the extreme scale
at the beginning of the podcast we
talked briefly about your CV and it's
phenomenally impressive but tell us a
little bit more about yourself how did
your interest in physics and theory and
engineering and math shape what you're
doing at Microsoft Research yeah so
because of him exposed to all of these
different areas it helps me really
appreciate all the different facets of
the problem that we're working on so the
theoretical underpinnings are extremely
important and then I've come to realize
how important the mathematical and
statistical modeling of the problem is
and then once you have built the model
then engineering a really good quality
solution how to do that what kind of
approximations to make that you start
from theoretically well founded
principles but then you make good
engineering approximations that will
help you deliver a world-class solution
and so it helps me look at all of these
aspects of the problem and try and
tackle them holistically so what about
the physics part actually to tell you
the truth I'm a miserable physicist
completely yeah I'm not very good at
physics unfortunately which is why I
switched you know I gotta be honest I'll
bet you're bad at physics is way better
than my good at physics so let's put it
in context right all right well at the
end of every show I ask my guests to
offer some parting advice or inspiration
to listeners many of them who are
aspiring researchers in the field of AI
and machine learning what big
interesting problems await researchers
just getting into the field right now
yeah you've been working for several
years but we barely scratched the
surface I mean there's so many exciting
and high impact problems that are still
open and need good quality solutions
right so if you're interested in theory
even figuring out what are the
theoretical underpinnings of extreme
classification how do we think about
generalization error and how do we think
about the complexity of a problem that
would be such a fundamental contribution
to make if you're interested in
engineering or in the machine learning
side of things then how do you come up
with algorithms that
bring down your training prediction and
cause and model size from linear to
logarithmic so can we have an algorithm
that is log time cleaning log time for
addiction load model size and yet it is
as accurate as a one versus all classify
that has linear costs and if you're
interested in deep learning then how can
you do deep learning at the extreme
scale how do you learn at the scale
where you have a hundred million classes
to deal with how do you personalize
extreme classification if you wanted to
build something that was be personalized
for each user how would you do that and
if you're interested in applications
then how do you take extreme
classification and apply it to all the
really cool problems there there are in
search advertising recommendation retail
computer vision all of these problems
are open and we're looking for really
talented people to come and join us and
work with us on this team and location
is no bar no matter where you are in the
world we're happy to have you level is
know as long as you're passionate about
having impact on the real world and
reaching millions of users we'd love to
have you with us so we've talked about
going from a hundred to a hundred
million labels what's it gonna take to
go from a hundred million to a billion
labels yeah that's really exciting and
that's actually some of the things that
we're exploring right now in fact not
only do I want to go to a billion labels
I want to go to an infinite set of
labels that will be the next extreme and
extreme classification yeah and that's
really important again for the real
world because if you think about
applications on being or it's search or
recommendation you have new documents
coming on the web all the time or you
have new products coming into a catalog
all the time and currently our
classifiers don't deal with that
thankfully we managed to cut down our
training costs so that you can just
retrain the entire classifier
periodically when you have a batch of
new items come in but if you have new
items coming in at a very fast rate then
you need to be able to deal with them
from the get-go and so we now are
starting to look at problems
where there's no limit on the number of
classes that you're dealing with well I
imagine the theory and the math and then
the engineering to get us to that level
is going to be significant as well but
it'll be a lot of fun you should come
and join us
Manik Varma it's been an absolute
delight talking to you today thanks for
coming on the podcast Thank You
Christian as I said the pleasure is
entirely mine to learn more about dr.
Monica bharma and how researchers are
tackling extreme problems with extreme
classification visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]